So many things have taken place and I know
people are eager to chat and tell me what
they're thinking of and what's going on.
And let's do it via discord at David Pakman
dotcom slash discord.
You can also join the discussion happening
on discord.
I think close to I think we've got close to
10000 people on our discord, which is a perfect
no.
Let's first go to let's go to Jill from Burbank,
Jill from Burbank.
You're on the air.
What is going on?
Hi, David, good morning to you.
It's morning over here.
How are you?
Pretty good, how about yourself doing well
as through raining in Burbank, so I was going
to ask you in regards to the policy.
What do you want to see?
You know, now the Democrats have the Senate
and the House and the presidency.
Yes.
What policies do you want to see?
I really want to see progressive, you know,
the green New Deal on the table debated.
What do you.
I mean, listen it, Jill, it's such a long
list, so first on day one, you know, day one
could mean the first couple of weeks Joe Biden
needs to do everything he promised to do via
executive order that he can do and reversing
a lot of the things that Donald Trump did.
I think using the Defense Production Act to
scale up vaccine production is something I
would I would be very interested in very quickly.
He and Democrats in the House and Senate should
be able to should be able to get a bigger
stimulus done.
Having Mitch McConnell out of power is just
such a fantastic thing.
And then I want Biden to get started on the
big things.
Let's get started on the public option.
Let's get started on the energy and climate
proposal that he did, which is not the Green
New Deal, but takes a lot from the Green New
Deal.
Let's do minimum wage.
I mean, it's such a long list.
It's all possible now.
But now is when the work begins.
And that's the thing.
There's I saw a lot of people gloating.
This is just the beginning.
This is we now have to actually get something
done and it's not going to be as easy as many
think.
But the list is very long and it's exactly
the type of thing we should be thinking of.
Right.
What do you think the student loan is going
to get passed at all, like student loan forgiveness?
He said, you know, I'm skeptical.
I'm skeptical that it's going to get passed
and that that one I would love to see something
done on student loans.
It's a huge priority and be very economically
stimulative to redirect money away from being
interest paid to banks to money people can
spend at local businesses.
But I am I have a skepticism that that gets
done in the next two years.
And I feel like that's the problem with, you
know, Biden and the difference between Trump
and Biden and Trump, you know, says something.
He just goes and writes whatever.
And, you know, it's it's an executive order.
Yeah, but let's not give Trump too much credit.
Trump did nothing on health insurance.
Trump promised health insurance.
Yeah, it's not.
Yeah, I hate him.
But he you know, he does that.
I wish you know that.
No, but I think the point is Trump has done
nothing on many of the it's not just that
Trump is he does bad things, but he does them
most of the stuff he promised, he just didn't
even he just didn't even come close to doing.
He just didn't do anything on.
I totally agree with that.
You know, just like, for example, for toilet
and stuff, you just when it does nothing really
what he wrote, but he goes ahead and writes
a writes an executive order.
But anyways, in regards to the manga people.
Yes.
The last question, what's the best way to
change their heart?
I mean, from my experience, I think showing
how we used to be know how we used to work
as a family friend is the best way.
But what do you think is the best way to do?
I don't think that there is any what I call
retail strategy, arguing with individual trumpet's
one on one.
It's there's no way.
There's no way we need a wholesale strategy
which includes cultural change, educational
change.
And it's a it's at least a decade process,
unfortunately.
And I know a lot of people want just like
what's the trick to convince these three Maggert
people I know to change their minds?
The problem is it's just way it's way bigger
than that, unfortunately.
Well, thank you so much, David.
Do do exactly what you're doing and we love
you.
Thank you.
All right, Jill from Burbank, very much appreciate
the call.
We are taking calls via discord at David
Pakman dot com slash discord.